عبد السلام ما الذي حدث في طول كرم وما هي
اخر تطورات حرب غزه نبدا من هذا التطور
اللافت في طول كرم حيث تتسع دائره
الاشتباكات مع قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ادت الى استشهاد 12 شهيدا فلسطينيا فيما
كان هناك اصابات في القوات الاسرائيليه لا
نعلم بالتحديد تفاصيل كثيره جدا عن ما حدث
لكن هذه جبهه جديده تفتح في ضمن صراع جديد
في حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه ما نعرفه
الان انه ارتفع عدد الشهداء في قطاع غزه
حتى هذه اللحظه تم تسجيل اكثر من
3800 شهيد والاصابات تجاوزت 12 ال اصابه
في تزايد سريع لاستمرار الاستهدافات
الاسرائيليه التي لا تتوقف حتى بعد
الاستهداف في مستشفى المعمداني ما زالت
الاستهدافات متواصله على جبهات عده تتركز
في الشمال وايضا في حي الشجاعيه ولم يخلو
الامر من استهدافات في جنوب قطاع غزه التي
الذي دعت اسرائيل السكان في غزه الى
التوجه اليه كان هناك ارتفاع في عدد
الشهداء في جنوب قطاع غزه الى اكثر من 81
الى 81 شهيدا مما يدل على انه لا مكان امن
في القطاع رغم ادعاء الجانب الاسرائيلي
بانه يدفع باتجاه الجنوب لايجاد منطقه
امان عدد الشهداء تتركز نسبته الاعلى في
النساء والاطفال 70% تقريبا من الشهداء
وحتى الاصابات هي في صفوف الاطفال
والنساء نتحدث ايضا في الجانب الانساني
وهناك ترقب لوصول المساعدات الى قطاع غزه
والدعم اللوجستي في هذا الاطار ما زال
الحديث مبكرا عن فتح المعبر لدخول هذه
المساعدات يترقب ان يكون يوم غد ال الجمعه
وضمن اطار محدد كما صرح الرئيس الامريكي
بالتنسيق مع الجانب المصري تصريحات لافته
للامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
جوتيريس تحدث فيها عن وجوب انهاء الحرب
والتركيز على الدعم الانساني للفلسطينيين
والسماح دون شرط او قيد لدخول المساعدات
لانقاذ المدنيين في القطاع